you
[Music]
my name is dr. Jim Norman I'm at the
Norman parathyroid Center in Tampa
Florida the Norman parathyroid Center is
the world's leading parathyroid
treatment center we operated about 3,500
parathyroid patients per year so our
challenge to nucleus medical was that we
needed a animation that could teach both
patients and doctors we had to get from
the very basics of what a parathyroid
gland is all the way through the complex
information for a doctor about what
parathyroid can do to a patient if left
alone this couldn't be done
none of this could be done without a
custom animation there isn't anything
off-the-shelf that can answer these
types of questions and working with a
nucleus team has been amazingly easy for
us and they've accomplished every one of
our goals the end result is a beautiful
animation that's been viewed many
millions of times in seven languages so
we really are accomplishing our goal
which is to teach the world about this
disease whoo reaching many people who
have nothing to do in our practice
we're just enhancing the education of
patients and doctors worldwide my
experience with the new face team has
been so good that we actually are now
starting a whole new product with them
they wanted to know what I wanted before
we even started
number two was professional
at every step of the way from from the
first phone call to translating the
video to the seventh language and the
third I would say expertise when we
needed something that looked a specific
way they made it happen so I'm very
happy today
you